relationships one or two Joanie and
Yusuf from pro pen fitness journey us
again relationships 101 when done really
well if you haven't watched it link will
be in the description and video coding
will make it appear around that clip of
you saying it doesn't have to be better
it just has to be different this from it
is indeed that Verizon sheet as
explained by Family Guy
not very BuzzFeed e-commerce baby but
what went down well so today we are
going to do relationships one or two I
think we're gonna talk a little bit more
about how to cultivate a good
relationship some principles that you
can stick to I've got some comments to
make about what seeing someone means
which is a no-man's land of emotional
distress so relationships one or two
where did we leave off last time we we
talked about the initial phase of like
having met someone to beginning
something some something slightly more
exclusive yeah yeah I think I want it
I'm gonna delve straight in I don't know
whether you two because both of you are
kind of let's serial monogamists right
ish like at least in recent recent
memory has certainly recently yeah yeah
um and I think there's a anyone who's
listening who's being used to being
single and hasn't been in like a proper
proper relationship for a little while
you will know the no-man's land of
emotional turmoil that is seeing
somebody hmm and I think that that it is
just absolute barren wasteland of
nothing less meaningless like it is one
step above having sex with being friends
with benefits and everything below being
exclusive there's a bit of commitment
but no reward so I think anyone who's
seeing somebody unless it's mutually and
absolutely transparently explained to
both parties just needs to give up on it
now you need to either step forward into
a relationship or step back into having
sex with other people as well and I'll
explain why
is offering of just you reminded me
about the friends-with-benefits thing
and I David was talking about this too
that we I think if you're just nice to
someone who is a friends with benefit
and a friend with a benefit yeah their
assumption because they're on the the
defensive is like whoa don't fall in
love with me now and you're like alright
lettuce head like I'm not gonna for them
I'm just just being nice
yeah but it's like the instant fear that
the other person is becoming too
attached yeah so I think the reason that
I don't like seems somebody and I can
speak from personal experience on this
what you think you're getting when you
start seeing somebody is all of the
benefits of having a regular girlfriend
or boyfriend with non of the it's down
the far side menu drinking you enough to
reach with none of the disadvantages
with none of the justification for them
to ask you where you've been or who
you've been messaging or whatever you
want to be able to have your cake and
eat it and I think that people believe
that it's as friends of benefits or no
this is seeing seeing someone I think
friends with benefits like it just so
quickly turns into seeing someone now
and the way that you pull that back it
the only way that you can do that in the
only way you can fix it is by being
completely transparent about exactly
what's going on and continuing to do it
all the time but what happens so
long-term friends with benefits like
truly situation has to either be two
Psychopaths or two really busy people
that just have very utilitarian
transactional relationship but I need
something from you you need something
from me a little bit completely lace its
bilateral prostitution where the feet
cancels each other out and so that both
breakeven again yeah and yet then you
looked at me like so yeah I think seeing
someone is just it's a terrible position
area you're repeatedly having sex with
the same person yeah it's it's not
anything else happen no so it's seen
someone is being boyfriend or girlfriend
with a partner without being the title
the label okay I guess what people
believe and what the chain feels
pedantry 101 thing like I don't
understand well it's a precursor isn't
it it's where both parties are too
afraid to what to say yeah if you see
you live you're spending a bit of time
for each other's houses maybe mmm good
you probably spent have spent a lot of
time with each other it's not
we aren't boyfriend and girlfriend and I
said I mean it the universal language
the universal currency of this is is it
Facebook official yeah like if it's not
listed on Facebook it's a great system
have you ever listed a relationship on
Facebook yeah I have really no one like
jonathan is seemed on my pro forma
exactly that's what you think it was
shock the diaphragm yeah
what why why why do you don't like
personal information being up in the
open absolutely not especially not a
relationship
I just think that's nobody's business
interesting but well it's my business
and they're the person's business yeah
and I suppose your business
Chris's business to degree is that don't
make any money off your relationship I'm
not sure it's my businesses or how did
he know that you don't in fact yes you
do yeah you're right I do
thanks for coming to my club nights
Beckett hmm so yeah basically I think
people believe that seeing someone is
this wonderful best of both worlds
scenario we're going to get
companionship balls or freedom and what
actually inevitably ends up happening is
it's a game of emotional chicken with
the other person then we've sliced
thinly sliced chicken in a pressure
cooker and what what you applied the way
that the game of chicken works is
whoever gets feelings first loses and it
just ends up it's a countdown clock to
someone doing something which crosses a
boundary that was never defined hmm like
if you sleep with someone else and you
haven't identified that you're supposed
to be exclusive with someone because
seeing someone is in this beautiful then
there's a slimy get out card for the
other nation be like oh well we never
said it we're exclusive so yeah actually
I'm at free rein to do whatever in this
light
there is kind of a code of honor where
yes that it hasn't been discussed yet
there's an implication it's it's a gray
area he does the russet but [ __ ] or get
off the pot really is the advice
philosophy I just think to stop being
scared and just yeah but one of the
problem is gonna sell about seven quid
an hour yeah things like the click of
that there yeah team will make sure that
that goes in so I think that basically
you need to you need to make a
commitment with regards to this sort of
stuff because you think you're getting
the best of both worlds and you're
actually not you're not getting anything
of either and because certainly for me
when I'm in situations like that if I do
start chatting to someone else or start
spending time with another girl or
whatever I immediately get these
horrible pangs of guilt about doing
something and then the thought loop of
well I'm not doing anything wrong well I
should be allowed to do this well
actually no because you and I know in my
heart parts that my deepest virtue says
no the fact that that thought loop is
going on yeah
is the internal it's trying it's up with
and the other thing if you go well you
never know what the other person is
doing I'll I'll do you know they having
such as it said that she's not gonna do
so you just keep on going back to either
they're not just the contracts and
lifestyle time constructively to
obligations may I mean even maybe you've
not got contracted Beckett I don't but
well no no that was wrong as you know
it's far they're morning to me I don't
have a contract education
I'm truck did you Arkady there is hope
you know the conclusion of relationships
101 well one of them where's that many
of these gaps that we see that cause
suffering are from lack of clear
communication hundreds in and in this
case it's exactly the same under so but
nobody can socially acceptable say like
our I'm too afraid of commitment to give
us a maple yet or I'm I'm still not sure
if I like you fully so I don't want jump
in cuz saying that is a social faux pas
in itself so then there needs to be a
way to either touch over but if both
people were separately disgusted with a
solicitor contract support to go get
versa
yeah Get Alerts are involved so that
this is my microphone
school so the like the the idea behind
tinder could work at the next level as
well which is that both people put in a
blog vote they don't get to see what the
other like steals share or steal yes to
prisoners dialogue because you describe
it as chicken which is exactly what it
is like it is game theory it's the
prisoner I know right if both people
split then fine if one person splits the
other person steals that's one person
cheating and the other person well not
cheating but and if they vote to fell
cheat then fun yeah I I just think it
it's such like as I see all the time
right I've got access to 200 under 21
year old guys and 200 into 21 year old
girls and much park and go hundred miles
long is the candle in the wind along the
old old wooden tree that's so outdoing
each other with rubbish I I have a
framework for this discussion
fantastic do you want to hear the
framework yeah cuz I think it would help
frame all of this great love a frame
question one is should we be in a
relationship at all
you asking me this is the beginning of
the framework Chris it's a rhetorical
question so a relationship versus being
signal and then once you decided that I
feel like I'm gonna put across as a
pretty strong argument you should be in
a relationship then who should he be in
a relationship with and then as I said
about to ask how do I find the person
I'm allowed to get married well exactly
and then once I found that person well
the next question is if I get them not
we're not covered in that in power
person is once you're in a relationship
with that person how do you keep that
person in a relationship with you
without you all in shapes without using
stuff like that or strong
strong like this isn't partisan the top
of the head
and circular motion yeah exactly uh Aviv
my Unversity moment sorry I was cheating
okay so I think we've covered I think we
covered most of the ones up to how do
you keep a relationship I don't think we
have I think let's go forward into
relationships because I've a cute I want
to do a whole one on single single time
I want to make one point yeah which is
that I think where a lot of people get
trapped look you look immediately bored
that's my that's my resting [ __ ]
second-hand car market that's what it's
like you're talking about this the other
day we discussed this and the big dicks
group didn't who did
so I think people so this is this is
under should I be in a relationship or
not so let's say you're 25 for example
and you're thinking I'm moving towards
30 quicker than I feel comfortable with
I'm not really happy with in my life is
I feel like maybe I should be getting a
relationship maybe a few your friends
are one of them's engaged cover them and
maybe having kids or some other try to
get 15 weddings in the last month
family meeting and so you business
decisions like should I be single or not
and I think there's a point at which if
you're not careful all of the people who
are people you would actually want to be
in a relationship with are in
relationships and then what you're left
with is rags yeah
so I'm scraping the bottom of the brow
which is like when you're buying a
second-hand car you don't know whether
it's a great value steel or whether it's
two cars that have been welded together
and they're giving you [ __ ] that's it
because what you've got there is there
is a statistical distribution of Ages
that people typically pair off I mean as
you grow older that total population
diminishes but also the average quality
also drops yep that's what we presume
that the cream gets taken off the top
first people taken off the top four no
matter what which brings the mean DOM
and so yes there still are high-quality
people on both ends of that up now
skewed bell curve
but you probably tied it to this fewer
fewer per sample size right and if you
have no sample size Allen smaller sample
size so it means the price is higher
which means you can be more attractive
and better in every way to access those
people the only way that this works and
you put it in the group I'm gonna use my
singing defense against this it's so one
who's 30 years old and single hit me I
should be by all means [ __ ] myself
that I don't have a girlfriend but
that's you presuming that I'm looking at
girls that are my age you so I agree but
it says likes it it's like if I said to
you there are the there is a range of
cars that you can buy so let's say cars
that were made in a 10-year period and
you can buy from them whenever you want
but everyone else is also trying to buy
from that pool of cars and some of them
make them back on the market some of
them may be kept in a garage and yeah
you can wait until the ones that are 10
years younger are coming up to 30 if you
want to or you can secure a position but
you sit outside of this entire equation
for a whole host of reasons that we're
not gonna get into in the pocket but for
the average person who doesn't have an
Instagram for these things neat and if
you wanna know the instructor Liz laughs
if you wanna know what that is send us a
message so I took I think another I
think another part too before you move
on from that okay I thought we covered
this you've opened the phone and you
don't enjoy so the age difference so age
differential is a big deal because we're
gonna have to get that picture up I'm
gonna send it to video point but this up
no sir it's a garage on a football the
boy is so it's a data plot of the
average preference of Ages that men
prefer that people prefer in the
opposite sex as defined by mass comm and
it's depressing because for women the
age that they prefer in men is typically
a year or two older than them maybe up
to five bends it then flips on for a
little while though right at the age of
like 50 and 60 they want someone who's
the same age and then slightly younger
for men the Asian work regardless of
their age is all 2121
and when I think when you're 40 you're
into the mic from the slightly older
woman at 24 and then it goes back to 21
that those bugs that's like 50 back to
121 you're enough enough is enough I
need to start liking okay actually focus
tried to 24 year olds I'm going for 21
you but I mean there is this probably a
there's a biological explanation for
that so I'm gonna I'm also gonna throw a
spanner in the works with that if I look
at a 21 year old girl now and I think to
myself emotionally unstable I think I
shall be boring to hang around with it
and like doesn't just because sorry doll
21 year old girls who are up there you
are lovely but you're going to be more
lovely in about three boring emotionally
unstable and less boring I think when I
was 21 I didn't find 21 year old girls
boring but I think as you have less and
less in common as you get older that's
cuz you wind it back to you with half
your age plus seven
that's the formulas the rules in this go
B formula so yeah I think I totally do
gather and I think that the elephant in
the room when you're talking about guys
versus girls is that women's biological
clocks tick yep a lot more harshly than
men's do so the men are seeking
fertility ultimately whereas for women
this isn't like 18 the mayor of Whittier
by the peak theoretical peak of
fertility in is that correct yeah would
you have your best chance of being
pregnant at 18 and it gets more
difficult thereafter I think so yeah Wow
which means that if assuming that's true
men are just gonna find 18 year old
which is supposed 20 ones close enough
isn't it 18 looks too much like or too
much like a child for me well I say I'm
saying I'm not saying like I'm saying
statistically speaking yeah with that in
mind that's how your programs right to
see which i think is is insidious to be
honest that that's what programming like
that why was Emily them doing all yeah
well it's just unfair isn't it but
there's so much about biology is unfair
but it wasn't it wasn't designed for
this time or place was it that's why I'm
sure you should change it yeah this
should I was a bit better that's okay
but could get in there yeah without
heads that thing we could do something
yeah maybe not so business versus a job
is like relationship versus being single
so or an asset versus an expense so
people think that being our relationship
is job versus business you must have
been looking that's crazy anyway okay we
all watch far too much of the same stuff
yeah too much Big Brother and love
Island and we're always watching so
we've just been doing before face mask
oh yeah cucumber you can put the key
people home through a vein people think
that our relationship is a liability
shall wait no no we're good we're
getting serious it's like when a teacher
in class that all right well I'm
guessing by your chattering then you
finish you don't pay now you don't want
to break the better for me not for you
um so job you get a salary and a pension
but at the end of a week or a month that
you have no residual value in that which
is the same as see see really dating
people so you build up a little bit
lacking something and then it disappears
build up a little actually disappears
with a business or an asset there's a
relationship analogy everything you do
like every good experience you have a
rememory career is is accumulating that
you are generating output is up your
analogy I think so I wrote this note in
August so totally does given that it
waits it's is it a singer you into much
better than you are the accountant
that's there is it a single-use
transactional kind of thing exactly it's
purely for the fleeting sense of
enjoyment you get while you're there
so that's interesting because we've
talked about this in a in a private
what's up in a circle thread the other
day which was that these these serial
experiences may have value of their own
they may not but the over arching value
could be that they are to give you
enough experience to prepare you for
being able to discriminate and pick a
better mate long term or to give you
enough experience enough width of
experience to know if you're in a good
or a bad position that's wrong I think
what what's interesting about what you
were talking about we'll come back to
the point about this game of chicken of
trying to find someone before they get
taken so to speak hmm what's interesting
there is the point that I made again in
the chat that we weren't about where I
said I don't know if I want to be the
first round for a 22 year old 23 year
old rocket who is going to be a
fantastic wife later in life but needs
to go through a divorce I do you don't
want to be a learning experience for
someone yeah yeah maybe I think maybe
not a divorce you know someone I mean I
like completely I think people who end
up marrying the person that the first
business luck with for example I think
that's a recipe for disaster that's like
person that's like putting all your
money into a single stock and just but
if the other thing as well is if you
don't know what you're missing ignorance
but big recess because that would be
fine if we didn't live in a very
sexualized society where it there's
hints of what you're missing everywhere
good point
so it's more than isn't like have I so
I've got that everyone's from signal
they're constantly yeah I'm gonna steal
a little bit of content from Brett
Weinstein Heather hanging in Joe Rogan
here but I don't think either of you to
listen to the podcast it's gonna be
quite interesting for the listeners at
home I'm gonna do a little experiment so
can you both imagine for me please a
woman who is beautiful
yeah but not hot it's like a 19th
century with it all know the current
Ottoman okay woman who's beautiful but
not hot just by our understandings of
those however you want to interpret it
for banal okay so you got that any month
yeah no that's the commonality
struggling it's not my offices okay okay
so can you now imagine someone who's hot
but not beautiful yeah okay so the
argument that Heather hang and Brett
Weinstein make on Joe Rogan's podcast is
that men's men's values that they're
looking for in women have become skewed
to work on hotness and not beauty and
beauty is timeless and it's the sort of
thing that continues throughout life so
a good example would be someone that
Dame Judi Dench or something like that
you know someone who's got some Beauty
some grace about it but you don't think
is hot hot but not beautiful would be
tardy girl yeah who you want to have sex
with but you wouldn't take onto the
parents I think that downhill from that
a downstream from that should I say
there's other implications about the way
that they hold themselves to the values
that they hold etcetera etcetera but
even if you just take it on the surface
level about the way that they look there
is definitely a distinction to be made
between beauty and hotness mmm um what's
happening with a lot of any beauty
products now Oil of Olay and whatever
else it is I don't know I'm just
thinking about what's in my mom's draw
that's the very month yeah oh yeah what
the girls use Maureen's not that will
super trays your age because it used to
be called oil and you late and then they
changed it to Olay just like the change
if to sit to his vote if that spanish
people can pronounce it wasn't it I
think men names like Willie in Swedish
or something oh yeah from the Swedish
sales so yeah the beauty and hotness
scale is something that's really
interesting and what they're saying if
the beauty product are signaling for
hotness and not beauty mm-hm
and this is confusing men's sort of
radar compass in terms of what they're
looking for as well because you really
want to be looking for beauty not
hotness
if hotness is going to wane within the
next five to ten years and this is the
same thing it's not the river is easier
to emulate hotness the next beauty
I think there's more depth to beauty for
sure I know feels like painted on please
services thanks a lot yourself yeah it's
a lot more flashy like to neon
Foster and less so and the other thing
is well that's kinda south it's easy
enough to get a tan and Botox and like
just all the like stuff that if you
looked at someone from a distance just
for a flashy but I was so very if you
think of like FHM cover model for
example well like you know what I mean
nuts and zoo and all that doesn't exist
anymore but yeah so like the the women
portrayed exampling nuts magazine but
they what I always just find so
interesting is like someone has arranged
that image in a way that they know guys
look at that and find whatever that
arrangement like whatever they're
wearing and that way attractive but like
a lot of it like if you saw someone
walking down the street lilac pillow
that's ridiculous but it's like the
combination of certain colors and items
of clothing that they know hotness
catering right I'd love to see machine
and learning algorithm come to a
conclusion
Gigi seems to turn people on watch it
did you read the post that I put in the
inner circle yesterday about the
snapchat filters and how they think yeah
do you read it no I did video I'm video
but yeah you enjoyed it yeah I suppose
that's close to machine learning
algorithms we're gonna get which is thin
you're explaining to make the argument
it's not chat the justice to facial
features based on these archetypes of
attractiveness to like smoothing out the
face make the cheek slightly redder make
the eyes slightly larger doesn't make
this forehead a bit larger as well right
basically make you have more of an e
Otterness
Li which means like baby like face right
so like you know the filter that has
like the floating here another one you
see so that's that's doing certain
things that makes the lips a bit bigger
that Pinkert right does this fish Aryan
runaway selection which is by sexually
attractive characteristics will become
more exaggerated over time so oh yeah
and it gets ridiculous it gets
absolutely becomes a caricatured so you
go okay men like women with big boobs or
women like men with broad shoulders run
that for a million years and you've got
these triangular men
women with like all the offices of our
province as I said yeah yeah yeah so
yeah so moving on
what's next any framework Christ should
we go I want to do how do you form a
good relationship so we've hopefully
managed to get people out of the mire
that is seeing someone and they've found
someone that they think I could I could
see myself in a relationship with this
person well so so I suppose picking that
person and knowing whether they are a
good choice and I Oh Johnny a huge
amount for there was a time a few years
ago a good few years I almost you tender
you yeah it doesn't time good for you
whatever wants a funnel when I was I was
quite torn and Johnny just advised me to
make a balanced scorecard if a couple of
people that I was considering pursuing
for a relationship and he was like look
like ranked them out Runk them across
five attributes market out of ten and
pick and give them each a rating on each
of those attributes take the total I see
which one has more points and however
long feel how do you feel that a lot of
people who would think you just know
that you just know campus man you feel
it when it's right how do you think they
would react this your I think there's
probably some overlap between one to
five or metrics I think back then I had
overridden my my my heart center my
feeling Center so much I think that's a
good point that I was out of tune with
that intuitive sense how do you feel how
do you feel note with regards to stuff
like that much better much better but
that's from a lot of spiritual practice
that I've done the thing that's
connected me know what's cool inside but
that's for another yeah another time
Johnny how about you how do you find
I'll choose a person that's right for
you in a relationship so I didn't I
didn't plot it out like that but that
approach X not really not excel sir so
put the with that I can respond to that
thing at that point if like I you
shouldn't approach it like that like
that's like saying you know someone
saying ah I'm just I know I'm saving
money or I know I'm losing weight or you
know I know I'm not breaking the speed
limit like you might be you might be we
might also not be and also like if you
know
if you know that you feel more strongly
about that person but you're struggling
to make a decision between one or three
relationships or whatever that you want
to get into like sometimes sitting and
actually thinking about it can think a
lot of a lot of relationships a lot of
what makes relationships special an
attractive adieu to the intangibles so
these aren't tangibles how do you
tangibly so like well prick by using the
framework like rules the fact that any
of us have had sex is impressive yeah
we're doing well so I the stuff that I
think's more important so stuff I
haven't been here yet when will it be my
turn
video game a video call you video VOD it
was just a two-dimensional image of him
like yeah I think we should make a like
vidya mandir represent like a little
character once we hit fifty dollars of
ad revenue on YouTube fifty dollars
I'm gonna spend no time you know
spending on animating deep fine we have
the consent right let's move up so the
things that I find are important so
defining your interests and values but
not in like oh I think you should be
honest and I let you know because I
bollocks personally so things like what
do you like doing on a Friday evening
and what's your daily life going to look
like yeah in that really feel about
certain personality traits how it like
how do you feel about like um so it's
something that bothers me is when people
back out or last minute for example like
having common interests inside common
feelings on seems like a good point
actually because sometimes what you like
you might have someone who's like art I
want the car with the six-pack and they
have no interest in training they're out
of shape and then if they find someone
and they actually find that their
interests are aligned and what they
would do on a week-to-week basis is
being different or then they feel like
they've had to be boy to the gym and
it's a phase they don't like but even
though so so I've actually found being
in a relationship with someone who likes
the gym not as good
personally because though because then
you then have to the gym beforehand
before the relationship was your time
yeah
and suddenly maybe a time it's not your
time but like I think there are
definitely benefits to having that but I
like the gym to be I go and people
criticize me for this but I go
headphones in like it's my time to to
just do that typical polished typical
part of that I always have commonly got
there I wanted to speak to Johnny but I
saw him in the gym and I was scared yeah
course of the day trust in biddeford
think about this rest I've got this rest
period to do show me show me one reason
he was doing a heavy deadlift session he
wants to sit and talk between sets of
you
I don't want well only fits through your
airports Wilder lifted ideally and not
only but something very so do you think
that having common interests with your
partner is important because Darren and
his wife is a good example
I've got they overlap in some areas but
calendars like wreath making and stuff
like loads of things that don't overlap
so and you're saying that having
interests that overlap is good but
they're going to the gym together is so
having what I want what I was trying to
say so something I said for
relationships versus single which is
that the pros of being single there are
only pros if you're in the wrong
relationship apart from obviously
sitting with lots of people where
they're supposed to sort of language
gesturing me when you did I didn't i
gestured in general you know but stuff
like having sex is not a big holiday
destinations interior design restaurants
like the type of music you might put on
the car where you might go and get some
food on a weekend stuff like that i
think is more important than to a lot of
people socially moved in to a lot of
people that would seem like real
low-level white surface
especially because you at the very
beginning of this framework you said
doesn't need to be about like loyalty
and
you know I just love it I think oil tea
is important but not as I stopped by so
you mean I think that just because I
think ephemeral nebulous terms of yeah
yeah what do you look for on like so I
gas this question loads and love island
right that's what you look for and what
they want is like blonde hair blue eyes
or brunette petite sporty goes to the
gym mmm loyal but actually your answer a
bunch of quite existential stuff that
they were I don't know it's finally free
and I found it really difficult because
if you don't have when someone asks you
that question what's your type hmm how
do you Hardy if you don't have a single
he's gonna say I go fit I go from only
blondes listen who is enough of a [ __ ]
or to think that that's an appropriate
answer well one is enough it's a very
inappropriate answer to it's stupid on
on that account but also like it's just
you've suddenly restricted arbitrarily
the pool of people that you could
potentially have met and then you might
meet someone who doesn't fit into your
completely arbitrary defined type in
your head that would have actually been
a really good match for you and your
present the mother for yeah going for
values is much better so anyway moving
forward into a relationship how do you
decide anything when its but it's time
and how do you ask someone to go from
seeing to mmm söderling there's an
elegant way to do that I think it's just
specially our range because like that
that question was acceptable when you
like 14 yeah and then now you feel like
such a generally comes back to I think
obviously throughout all of a
relationship especially towards the end
but like towards the end once you're in
a relationship it's super important but
this is just identifying how important
communication is like transparent
communication mmm Jonah Peterson on a
recent podcast I watched talks about him
his wife and he's adamant I think that
being together my we've 35 years he's
known as since she was eight you've
literally lived on the same street as
each other in I think it's Alberta
worries
and he said that she's never lied to
ever she believes that uh me his wife
has never ever once lied to you've got a
say as far as you know we're gonna say
that joy yet but it's gonna be a caveat
in him everyone made you only it's only
what you know but um but any beliefs
that she's never ever light and you're
like [ __ ] that is the basis of a [ __ ]
good relationship right there
hmm how much of a pessimist or I could
be like my wife is such a good liar that
I've never but I mean if that is true
and he chooses to believe an alternate
reality he's happy the truth okay so to
ask someone do you just why don't you
just request it on Facebook not speak to
her right in the wall girlfriend
question mark you're either gonna get a
yes or a no on you that might be the
reason for the no that's the traffic I
think this is something that we went to
see Eric Helms in a fitness seminar and
he in in passing in the fitness seminar
gave me the best relationship advice
I've ever had very unromantic but it was
really good advice well just so I think
a lot of people and I had this thought
up until that point was that like you
will have this relationship where you're
like I am in love with this person this
is I need to get married to this person
this is the one and all those sorts of
like romantic beliefs that look like
Cinderella and all these things like
lead us to believe and he uses ass
example if he was on an army base where
there was over a thousand people and he
knew rationally that there maybe be
fifty people that he could have formed a
relationship with his wife happened to
be one of those fifty people and then
that sort of fits like he finds her
attractive gets on with her etc and then
past that it just has to be two adults
understanding that relationships come
with a whole host of shape stuff and
problems and you just have to agree to
solve them cuz I remember in the heart
of the way he was like I'm getting
married soon and someone was uh issue
the one he was like well I I love her
very much but I don't really think there
is such thing as the one I mean issues
okay in in the world right now it was
probably between one or two thousand
people that qualifies as the one
your geographical overlap but you know
she's definitely one of those one or two
thousand people so do you believe do you
get it do you agree that the best that
you can hope for is someone who's good
enough so that's a that's a difficult
question good enough is determined by
your input as well yeah like so it's the
best that you can hope for good enough
because they men is what isn't like gear
that you find the most perfect perfect
person to you on the climb so there's
two numbers isn't that to me it's gonna
make my son was race or even count it
listen our tops you're less than hundred
now you learn 100 kilos you get less sad
face so headland awards are them you can
mix them on who on their side they are
perfect and they're putting in loads of
effort but if you don't meet them at
heart you will end up with a subpar
relationship look at that's fun what
means that means I supply appertaining
that means if they were different if
they were different and we're able to
account for whatever failings or
shortcomings or forthcoming sees that
you have that would be fixed the same
way that two jigsaw pieces put together
can make a whole mmm so it's more like
that let's say that you both are a
multiplier and you both got up to ten
points so if you both put in 100% effort
and you're both really well compatible
you can get a total of 100 if the person
is perfect and they put in the extra so
they're being used up their five points
of innate character and the other five
points of their efforts of out of ten
and you only put it in a three then
you're missing out on right person that
still doesn't affect what that person is
my question was so you think that the
best that you can hope for is someone
who's good enough so I think there has
to be a million that answers that
minimum minimum I think what Chris is
saying is like you're saying there is
quality when there was a magnifier which
is effort and person yeah and you put
them together but you I mean you you put
I suppose you put a cap on it so they
can only go up to ten but I think Chris
is saying like someone could be 7 or 3
someone could be 3 lots of effort or 7
but you could so I'm going to be
attending you could think this is a 10
oh actually I've just met someone who's
a 12 us it's that this is the reet this
is why you need to have lots of or why
you were saying you have lots of short
experiences when you're young so that
you get it's also the
a balanced scorecard because I know I
kept this hidden answer your question so
so let's say you appraise people over
three things like their personality like
a certain aspect of a personality that
looks in that job for example and you
want those three things to be maxed out
as high as possible you're with someone
who's eight across all three things you
meet someone who's ten and think that
person must be better more than likely
that person will have at least one
downside but that you don't know
principally they will have a downside
which is that that person is inherently
in high demand from everybody that they
meet which will lead to an inherent
downside so they're more like socially
valuable someone is the more it's so
complex isn't it because although
someone might appear like a 10 from a
distance and you get into a relationship
with them you are actually but that's
you can have the converse as well
you know and another thing to consider
it in the rough and another thing to
consider as well is that when you've got
someone who potentially is heavily
sought after hmm let's say that it's
someone that you think would be
intimidating or maybe you up themselves
and you actually find out that they're
very hungry for a real connection
because they keep having these what so
shall you yeah yeah absolutely think
that they have shallow connection and so
on and so forth I think that there's
probably too many variables to even
define it but I think that the Eric
Collins thing is quite nice that it's
there's probably out there right now
even for the people that have the most
in love that they can imagine if they
weren't in love with that person and
another person had to come a lot of that
person had never existed they weren't in
that situation another person came that
they could be equally happy with that
person and the fact that you're
separated by not only space
geographically balls a time like Alain
de Botton says we are often it is likely
that we're not we're never going to meet
the people who are best created to
understand us maybe we were born too
soon or too late or maybe we were in the
wrong part of the world hmm yeah like it
could be someone in a hundred years time
that would be absolutely perfect it
might even be in the same city but like
how likely is it that you're gonna meet
every there you go so why is it why is
it that people continue to get into
relationships with people that live on
the street Jordan Pearson's in a
relationship with someone that did that
yeah is the location a refining
characteristic which makes someone more
appropriate for a relationship or is it
just convenience it's both like the data
shows people at worth for this is skewed
by that exactly but people tend to go
for someone who is of a similar from
similar location religious views
political views socioeconomic status
income level like all of those things
seem to match with Vienna and they tend
is that because your values are derived
from those and means the aliens are
likely to have more in common in terms
of the way to give you the world I think
that's very likely isn't it but also
that they are probably the social
circles that you are more likely than
availability bias here as well you're
not gonna go find someone in finding the
- and marry them unless you happen to be
there any way in which case later is
there a case for you if you get to 30
years old like me just spending two
years traveling the globe sampling I
mean look yeah I think that's probably a
really good idea right - would you be
you you know you were saying like if
someone is a very desirable person and
even with them that immediately brings
down or if that immediately throws a
spanner in because other people are
fawning over them would that annoy you
if you're with someone who men we're
constantly trying to pick them up so I
think it depends on your level of self
confidence but also because like it can
be a point of real issue so I've seen
some relationships fall apart because a
girl was in a photo with a guy on a
night out the guy's very insecure and it
it just that's how nice a problem it is
completely a girl's problem but but the
guy would as a result probably be happy
with someone who got less attention
which is ridiculous but are you talking
about again that's good someone whose it
is and it's someone who should be
working on themselves before getting you
in relationship so you need to know it
you need to know yourself and you need
to know what level of notoriety you're
prepared to have of course yeah your
partner at the trouble is with all of
this so if we assume is that that's a
Newcastle for
one person there's 500 people so that
light and then for each one of those
people there's 500 people and we're in a
market that is getting smaller and
smaller over time because all of those
500 people are trying to find one of
their 500 people hmm
if you say I require 8 8 8 and actually
all that's remaining of the 500 is 100
and one of them is 7 7 8 and you go well
I'm gonna wait for Oh
9 9 8 and that person never arrives then
you may only be left with 6 6 things it
sounds an awful lot like because of the
market closing up as yeah yes yeah but
then every so often trades get reopened
well precisely but they're not ready
with the capital available what the best
way to do is put by ordering so valleys
can put in a buy order though if if only
you could his division so moving forward
to from using market traders easy work
out we're in a relationship you manage
to get yourself into a relationship with
someone that you think is not a complete
[ __ ] I think that this particular
area and I am not unfortunately we're
now almost outside of my domain we step
into a relationship I've been in lots of
long-term relationships just very
unsuccessful ones so I think you might
even be the best person to answer that
then like the you ask the guy who's been
divorced 15 times for marriage advice
and people are well that's stupid but
actually but he's seen the most mistake
well as I'm saying would you rather ask
a successful or a failed entrepreneur
for business advice because this is a
survivorship bias versus well because
the successful entrepreneur has likely
still failed it's it's just that one has
only failed and one has failed and since
then what you want is the guy who's been
divorced 15 times but not as happy
moment happy for the last 10 years
yeah so I think one of the most
important periods in a relationship is
like the first four to six weeks and I'm
aware that the precursor to this has
already been served by the time you've
spent before like the seeing them you
know this needs to really be from it as
soon as you start to spend time with
someone and the framework to apply to
this is kind of the same as
you're in court and there's already been
a case which has laid out how this
should go forward okay if you set a
precedent for ex situation to occur that
is what this other person will expect as
you move forward yeah and then changing
it is going to result in some sort of
turmoil mm-hmm so the way that you
should I think a good way to approach
the beginning of a relationship is to
sell the first few weeks as perfectly as
possible to have everything exactly as
you would like and to set the bar
incredibly high so everything's clean
date night done on time you greet them
as they come in the door you don't miss
out on x y&z you treat them in hold them
to as high standards as you want them to
be held to you set hardlines in the sun
going back to relationships 101 very
very hard lines in the Sun this is
acceptable behavior this is unacceptable
behavior
because as soon as you concede behavior
which he deemed to be unacceptable you
can no longer say it's unacceptable in
the future
oh well you all you already said it was
fine what do you mean I've been going
out with John I've been going through
coffee with John for ages you never had
a problem with it before it's like the
first time that something happens which
makes you feel upset tell them and
conversely the first time that something
happens that makes you feel nice makes
you feel good
tell them as well so another Jordan
Peterson one here the same way is
training a dog like it's exactly what
you're doing here you need to not only
punish we're not that much more advanced
than dogs really so don't you have you
need to you need to punish stuff that
you deem to be wrong and you need to
reward stuff that you deem to be good
and that will guide your partner to what
being the right person for you and I
think this is where it the whole
conversation about being with someone
but finding the right person for you
becomes even more twisted and because
you can create the person that's perfect
for you I've seen that so much where
someone is in a relationship with
someone you can clearly see that they're
only seeing a projection of what they
want that person to be and they're not
really seeing that person do you not
think of lighting when someone doesn't
meet the criteria that
into the idea of them in their head I
think a good characteristic to look for
in any potential future partner is
someone who's open to change and also
keen on personal development if you get
those two things it's likely that you're
going to be able to grow with that
person doesn't be like as you want them
to improve they want you to improve you
can hold them to a higher standard but
they don't take it as an insult or a
slight against them or some kind of
worrisome reason that you're not going
to care anymore and I think setting the
tone to setting the tone in that kind of
a manner make the forms a really really
good foundation it's like if you start
off a marathon running a six-minute mile
pace or whatever it is and you continue
it that you're like ok well that's my
split I'm gonna stay at six mate if you
start at ten minutes like what's the
incentive to speed up or how do you
speed up very low what about the desire
for growth as well because then if you
are with someone who is a waste man or
waste woman and you're growing at this
pace and they're staying the same
there's gonna be resentment you might
even start to resent that person both
ways as well they'll only resent know
for making progress and then just being
men so it's not like you can blame them
for not wanting to grow because do you
think that this do you think that
there's a typical difference between men
and women with regards to how much
they're prepared to grow in your
experience and relationships like you
are obviously using it both ways I've
seen where the woman is like really gang
a gang a stuff together and like really
moving forward with a life but the guy
is like I sort of layabout occasionally
violent and so on but because of that
because she still loves him she puts up
with it
but then you can see them grow further
apart but and then the other obviously
things like kids or whatever holds them
together or even the threat that if you
leave then I'm gonna do one if the fact
that as a society we're even to have
people [ __ ] cohabitant not tear each
other's eyes out on a daily basis is
amazing isn't like he's such a minefield
and the fact that were held in place by
social stigma or in a little bit of
virtue life it is really really
impressive the thing that I find amazing
is that people see their career as like
something that requires a lot of work
and a lot of time but a marriage just
happens you know I well I signed that
thing and I look for service and now I
think I'm looking back at these notes
and I think you took my phone one day
because I've got similar thoughts
because also you wrote you put glassy
yeah because if annoyingly I was looking
for them this morning I was like where
are they so you wrote if you bought one
pair of shoes you would pick carefully
yeah I think that's the right that you
so I remember what that means not while
you're looking through that I've got an
idea
two burdens were benefit to float with
you cancel love it from us so there's a
there's an idea that I heard from this
guy I think it's very reductive I think
it's very simplistic but he claims and
I'm sure there is an equivalent for men
but he claimed that women can be full
for long three different Continuum's
continuer someone's gonna have fun in
here on that yeah they will bit like one
this is I'm relaying this guy's idea
like if we had something big what is the
sort of man just as much a user would
say I'm sure there probably is an
equivalent model kissed on eelinators an
upsell so three different spectrums
spectra spectrums it's a spectrum it's
in news go on go on YouTube as a single
the think you know so goof
so you have their views towards men
relationships and their life so for men
there either tester or investor so if
they're a tester and they have lots of
men orbiting them at one time that
they're constantly keeping just kind of
her arm's reach and just always testing
them whereas an investor is a woman that
decides on one man and in put all her
eggs into that basket and dives in
and so they're usually on one side of
that spectrum or another the next one is
attitude towards sex which is either
denier or justifier and this is the same
way that they would react to hey did you
eat that chocolate in the fridge no no I
didn't with that's the denier that's
like sex is a naughty subject and if I'm
questions about it I'll just deny that
it exists and that I have any urges or
anything like that and if they and
they're less likely to cheat on you but
if they do you are not going to know
about it
a justifier is to do eat that bigger
chocolate well yeah that's just a bit of
chocolate like what's the problem
someone who doesn't see sex is very
important it's more likely to have sex
with you earlier in a relationship but
doesn't consider it to be anything
significant or any kind of marker of how
much they like you and they are more
likely to cheat on you and you're more
likely to know about it then you have so
you have justifier and Tenaya then you
have attitude towards life realist and
idealist
so realist is career-focused
realizes that they're going to be
juggling a lot of stuff and doesn't have
a kind of very romanticized view of
their life in their career idealist is I
want to be the princess of my house
model to have a three-bedroom house with
a little car and a dog and a driveway
and that and that's that's the the
idealist kind of more traditional istic
view of their life so you have tester
investor towards men realist justifier
denier towards sex and then realist
idealist towards life and career I've
heard you use that before to recall from
our part Munson no similar guy I
remember Darwin me talk I think if you
have I've run it by a few a few women
try to see where they like and then I
think the tendency is ever ugh well I'm
a denier and justify whatever it's what
you do with that information and what's
wrong is it accurate or is it just
random dichotomies that someone's
created to some stuff if it's not
pertinent to how
someone's gonna behave in a relationship
like it could just be where their
principles lie but if they love you that
much that they can compromise all of
those things to be whatever it is that
you want hmm
but what do you want someone
compromising who they are it's a good
question I think that there are the HUS
to be compromised you don't even if it's
just to the extent of like because I
said again a lot of arguments that I've
observed happening in relationships
especially like at uni when you
everyone's a very sort of closed
environment is just ego overriding and
like someone won't because so easy just
go you know what I'm sorry my bad I'm
like wait you know that go it's not it's
not that easy or well easy relative to
having a three-day argument where you
think that why so many people and three
their arguments clinging on to the ego
because it yeah okay so take take this
as a lesson just like ours just so sorry
mmm I think that's enough you let's
imagine in like a really severe mall
thing I mean it moving up moving onto
that like I think breakups ah the most
painful because of pride hmm I would
honestly go as far as to say that more
than half of the pain in most
relationships but most breakups from
relationships a Jew to the pride you
know being hurt because Pete it just
triggers so many feelings of
worthlessness and self-loathing and it's
why I knew I knew I wasn't good for this
person all along or all of that sort of
stuff I think that's the reason that it
hurts and that can be shown there's been
a couple of times where I've been sort
of with a girl or whatever and then
we've split up I've maybe not by my
choosing or maybe we've kind of drifted
apart and then I
again [ __ ] no-man's land of seeing
someone you don't really know what's
going on
and he may have a little bit resentment
towards them but then if they come back
and you get to sleep with them one more
time gone neutralized
absolutely just immediately gone because
you like the pain from the break-up yeah
because you're like how droll a lot
don't need to worry okay it's happened
at least three times to me where I've
been like that breakups stung a little
bit more than I thought it would
I've got some residual resentment a
little bit bitterness a little bit this
lever that gets leave with them again
like lots of worrying about cuz it I
suppose it damages your ego but yeah
like am i desirable am I not desirable
they're saying I'm not like someone
getting rid of something what do you
think like everyone always says like
they want to be able to say oh it was
mutual and if they had a breakup they
never one person who pushes it one yeah
so what do you think about this
statement the power in a relationship
lies with the person who cares the least
it's probably true but I think a
successful relationship shouldn't have
to rely on power struggles and and games
of who cares and who doesn't care issue
if it's a case of both people put it
like that the person who suffers the
most is definitely the one who cares the
most but if you can you see any of that
the power in the relationship lies with
the person who cares least in your
previous relations the same if I can in
any negotiation you will have someone
who cares a Leeson is most able to walk
away and they are going to be the one
that has the bargaining power but I so
I've definitely experienced that I think
it when it happens it's when there isn't
a shared vision for where it's going I
think like if both so back to the
ericom's advice of like it's just
problem-solving by a just professional
problem-solving and an issue like that
there's just your two people who live
together and share a lot of your life
together shit's gonna happen that's like
as minor as I was watching that
what are you doing this I like why did
you make me feel this way I really you
know all these sort of things and it's
managing someone else's feelings and
emotions and helping them understand
that how you feel about what your
motions are and if you have a share
shared view of where things going and
that that's another feature that you
both want to be the case and you won't
argue about the small stuff because it's
because it's like well I'm moving in
this direction so I've written a matter
well here no Arlena
and that a little relationship is like a
business and in the same way that like
Yousef and I went on are like well we
are suppose we are on a relationship in
a way and but I won't let him have sex
with me ever
much to my keeps trying but the point is
is that like the little stuff is
irrelevant because there's a shared view
of whether we'd like the business ago
location yeah
and so but I think if someone let's say
the Yousef didn't give a [ __ ] and I
really cared then the arguments are just
gonna rock yeah so we've kind of jumped
ahead to the breakup things I think we
can probably get away with a full
Episode on breakups so I want to shelve
that for now how are you Tim as well
yeah how do you after the honeymoon
period of a relationship drops off where
do you go from there now have you got a
framework for how you keep that's a
million-dollar question isn't it
and that's not got a fairly successful
long-term relationship yeah how do you
use a fairly successful framework for it
as well as though we're asking well for
the love of God give us some haven't got
a [ __ ] girlfriend it's so the answer
is unfortunately deadlifts have three
and Ricky doesn't over great a leg to
body volume uttered though is it come on
so why are you like so so I wish I knew
how I just sell the answer just quit
quitting I'll tell you people get
physical delivery and quit post ringing
first ago so so I think I personally I
feel the and I don't feel like I created
it I feel like it's just happened but
the relationships that I see that are
just in utter turmoil all the time tarz
button that says yes bit i when like one
of the one of the relationship like the
man or the woman just wants to stay in
all the time which once about the man or
the man or the amount of the man sorry
sorry
to people in our age or the non-binary
or that oh yeah or there's mmm the other
kid knows so I think they are one of
them is forcing the other person to live
their life with them and the other
person wants to see their friends or
wants to do something else without them
for a while and that creates arguments
and problems I think to me a successful
long-term relationship is two people
sharing their life in tandem and each of
them have suffered liddie like separate
receptacles in transit and yeah yeah but
it's there's a lot of shared time but
doing something else isn't a deal
breaker so I think not that's the whole
thing of like I don't like you don't
make me whole I make me whole and then
we come together and yeah yep Will Smith
it's big on this occasion the worst
myths of women roles at The Fresh Prince
will ever what fresh fruits of Bubba is
just started up a pretty successful
YouTube channel he is honestly he has
and I his horizon wisdom video guy video
guy Dean has VMD has a stiffy over Will
Smith video content you okay the souls
not so turgid he can see his face in the
reflection anyhow we start to leave
actually yeah that's a crank one out of
a Will Smith's video content yeah double
ganger yeah yeah so you think that it's
a combination of you retaining your own
life and your own interests and which
gives you that sense of Independence
would not make you feel - stifled before
I yeah these vascular or and also having
enough time together to maintain that
level of contact and feel like you're
progressing together and stuff like and
it sounds stupid but like really
listening to someone when someone's
speaking making eye contact when they
walk in the room they ask sitting and
asking them how their day is without
being on Facebook at the same time
why is the standard like women come like
a stereotype women comes in hi darling
you're right and it's like guys playing
xbox
doesn't look at her just like either
makes a grunting noise or just but again
we don't again with that if you set the
tone from the very beginning of your
relationship
and again another job piece and
sample here if you want if you're as a
man you want to be greeted by your wife
as you come through the door tell her I
won't you greet me at the door
I wonder you kiss me on the cheek and
say how was your date and then you can
go back to whatever you do but I want
that to happen like if that's a
non-negotiable thing that's fine if
you're not asking someone to set
themselves on fire mm-hmm you're asking
them to come to the door and say how was
your day
like apps and if here's a girl if you
don't want to have to wait for longer
than two hours for a reply and a message
set that as a rule in the sunt like
frameworks are the way the business is
the most complex organizations
absolutely inconceivable the people
listening who are in a relationship now
have felt like they've made too many
concessions from their values and
they're like is this irrecoverable now
is anything so that the answer is always
if you're gonna summer that something
couldn't no yeah so obviously not a
third that I think I think that it's
good a good opportunity or a good chance
to do that would be to have a reset so
every year for ourselves me particularly
I know you two aren't quite so big on
New Year's resolutions but I'm massive
on them every year I reset my own
personal values me controlling me is a
lot easier than me controlling me and a
relationship so having a yearly review
for myself and not having one for the
relationship seems almost backwards like
if you're in relationship where you feel
like you have compromised too much and
that things are starting to go astray
from where you wanted want them to or
you thought they would or whatever it
might be
ask the person like let let's sit down
and let's let's talk about the things
everything so we say this to the boys
perfect example our managers get
overworked when they're doing club prom
or they've got university degree to
juggle with late nights and some long
days that we make them work and I have
increasingly encouraged them to come to
me as soon as something gets
that it perfect example not very long
ago one of the boys had a art
dissertation thing in and he just had
one week where it got a little bit much
room and he came to me straight when
he's a man like I just wanted you know I
just struggled my way with my work that
last week and immediately the pressure
release valve just went and I was able
to shuffle a couple of things around and
that was fine but if he'd left that and
the situation had got worse over the
space of eight weeks he believed because
he go I can't take this and one bag we
were floated suffer as well everything
would degrade so I think have a every
six months or every year like pick a
time but make it Valentine's Day make it
new year make it something every single
year have a sit down MIDI part okay so
what do you think went well this year
what would you change like and going to
it openly this person isn't saying to
you I don't like who you are the saying
that we could be better together and I
would be happier if you if you do this
it's not comment on you as a person and
the fact if you can do this completely
transparently and as long as you're not
saying like I hate the size of your
penis I wish you had with smaller
nipples like father feedback there's a
smothered feedback but ever make it may
be difficult to swallow and what the
small penis is what you do about you you
large fried egg nipples lady and there's
more penis yeah softer you inside and
make up for another Rose I see you kiss
them on the cheek if they come through
the door fine um I just think you know
tiny penis I just think that's a very
good advice though to say that is a very
good advice yeah thank you for being
advice with us yeah it may be six
monthly reviews and maybe we'll
definitely do it across the multiple
dimensions urination there's a guy who
speak to be spoken about this and he was
on a pollen count Jay wise none of
that's something I'm a phillips-head
there's a guy he was like every quarter
I asked my wife to oh yeah for me there
is he was it and it's like yeah so have
a total and he can like be [ __ ] it's
someone we both follow be [ __ ] with kids
for a bit benefit was cuz you've done
loads of business trips and you know
he's doing awful
not with an intel KD for a bit as long
as he's not she's in two areas two
months from two cores in a row that's
alright because that what I do I think
they're like one thing to go back to go
back to what we're talking about
generally I I'm gonna guess that there
might be some people home that are
thinking this sounds like a very
unromantic way and to operate a
relationship mmm-hmm but as I've just
identified there it's like are you
really a romantic I wonder the last time
you like wooed your wife with a rose
between your teeth and like spin around
without without there being a goal or
outcome based decision behind it that's
it it's just a puttin out the criticism
of that's unromantic is the people who
say that guarantee or not romantic
they're not real time they were their
idea of relationship and they have it
they won't have successful relationships
almond almost hit me for very long the
idea is think like an artist work like
an accountant that's the nice way to put
it
have you just come up with us no it was
someone saying that the great performers
or whatever the wrong thing artists and
not likely nonsense a good point about
romanticism as well I like for a very
very long time in human history we
didn't just have one partner and we
didn't marry for love we married because
the person that lived in the farm next
door lived in the farm next door I might
as convenient yeah it was a marriage of
convenience it was a marriage for power
it was a tool of bureaucracy it was a
tool of uniting or stopping wars United
Kingdom's together stuff like that there
was debris Marcus territory now isn't it
where we started saying like I marriage
is only a social thing and we're not I
think there are things I think romance
in its current form as was created in
the Renaissance period can be seen as
that the Romeo and Juliet kind of
approach to things I think it's much
more empowering to treat it as a
sequence of inputs and outputs because
that allows the problem to be first
identified and then rectified as opposed
to it bail or were just not right for
each other well not having a second what
the [ __ ] do you mean we're not right for
each other like what is not right can it
be fixed an input process output so I
fully subscribe to that way of thinking
I just think it's easy
for everybody if everybody reads about
us rather than getting like because it
seemed also in emotion as soon as
someone gets emotional about all these
emotions in bed relationships looking
getting in the way you see three people
on the spectrum why can't we all just
some spreadsheets really is it's just
tangible in the room isn't it yeah but
like having honest difficult
conversations if everyone's just willing
to do that and laugh and try and come up
with solutions to problems as long as
both people are willing to approach it
by that then pressure-relief felt like
it says it's like imagine if this is
what I'm saying like a relationships
like a business imagine if like the
board of huge companies just one of them
just walk out you know what this is just
isn't working like the entire world but
in a marriage that's what people think
is a solution even though there is still
an outcome focus with two people in
probably but like if it went when the
Tesla share price dip 20% and Elon Musk
walked out of the boardroom and said he
was gonna go stay with his mother I bet
his I bet when all that was happening I
imagine he just goes he's have a meeting
Laura because there's just no room for
especially when about this kids kids
involved and like there's a fallout of
the decision
it is totally irresponsible to get
emotional and make rash decisions now I
think all of that again comes down to
fear of communicating and so and they
justified by hiding behind this like oh
well marriage isn't supposed to be a
planned thing because romanticism and
everything and so but [ __ ] the runner
but at every stage from just meeting
someone to seeing someone to start in
relationship to long term perpetuating
relationship all of the gaps come from
even though they're different problems
of each stage come from poor
communication a new person and being
afraid of saying something that might
offend some more hearings answer or yeah
here in the truth yeah everyone should
learn the basics of sodor judo and so
judo why do i do are you gonna do you're
gonna flip your wife so we
you know even allowed to perform any
strikes it has to only be a rat
something wait if you leave a bruise
like I doing I disagree it was just a
weird thing as so what do you say
selling selling yeah wait you son I says
you have to combine you two with one
other things am i cuter than selling to
be so this was gonna be a li [ __ ] was
everyone should learn the basics of
marketing and sales because like in a
relationship you have to put across your
view and try and bring someone else's
view in line with yours and both people
have to try and do that and if both
people understand how emotion gets in
the way and how things can be removed to
arrive at a decision so much of you I
think it's difficult and this has
happened
sometimes with me in a relationship when
I've been discussing an issue hmm if
you're particularly good at selling or
there is the whole time yeah yeah well
that's why don't you limit basically
what the problem with that is that it
doesn't the fact that someone saves yes
in the moment
mm-hm doesn't actually mean that that's
what's right because they've been like
you've sold someone on to a program that
wasn't it wasn't like a doing right firm
imagine a world where you both just
closing the show of each other all time
yeah and you're on loads of
subscriptions you can sign up to I think
I just I don't like it's difficult if
you if you're able to box someone up in
the discussion and your partner isn't a
contender for you with regards to how
they're able to articulate themselves or
hold themselves in a debate or you can
just stand there on ground if they're a
little bit more if they're more
conscientious or a great more agreeable
sorry yeah put them on a cold calling
course so there's in immunize them
against be really you're trying to sell
the monster oh I think more what I was
trying to get out was like you very
quickly become immune to to [ __ ]
difficult conversations how often should
have sex as long as you want
how often should you have sex in a
relationship minimum so I like I know
like everyone's different and you gotta
have actually be the apana but I I
reckon
any less than once a week then things
are starting to vary I think the only
exception is you're living together this
is stuff like no no like you're away or
well obviously I well you have to be
where three let's see it the very what
you see readiness that you can just yeah
or one note effects like Angeles up that
game
oh yeah yeah so once a week once a week
a need to have sex to be button and I
think like and I don't there's a problem
the Chevy thing in as well that's the
sort of thing there's it's happy yeah I
want I want to hear you tell the story
about when the reminder came upon the
location and the name of this is fun and
I think I think it has to be has to be a
priority you're right yeah is it like
especially I mean I don't know but I
imagine as soon as you have kids and the
scene is like getting loads of [ __ ] to
do and it's easy to just get like bump
to the bottom of the to-do list
however frequency is one element of it
but I think with these six monthly
reviews or quarterly reviews you need to
assess quality as well because there's
no point having lots of bad sex really
part when no one comes it's just
ineffective training isn't it no is no
one orgasm time time and attention
there's no games no one's gonna get any
games everyone's just for joining us one
of those things that yeah it's
uncomfortable to talk about that stuff
especially like out the bit but it has
to be done away from a bedroom it's only
it's awfully uncomfortable why because
if it's in the moment people always I
see I thought you meant them just the
room but discuss the finer points of
house [ __ ] I am
insert in bed during say yes yeah
exactly like no one's gonna don't
condone it up there stop pinching that
is why you don't get off me yeah you are
you yeah and something that top tip for
anyone that's wanting to reignite
something like that in their
relationship is to look into Tantra
because it's a great way to build
intimacy but also connection with with
like a physical connection with your
partner by breathing together and so we
try and direct energy around your body
yeah you can't do to it like you do a
thing were so you've didn't move for
ages yeah this exercise where you sit
opposite each other
chest chest and you just breathe no
10-15 minutes it was during sex you can
do during sex as well so you didn't move
range of exercises yes is there like a
12-week program there's a couple of I'll
give video caighdeán a couple of videos
to put in the links in the show notes if
what if you spend so much time inside
the other person without moving that you
become infused together
that's the youngsters nature profuse
Kemah happen so like things coagulate I
watch him he goes do you need to be
inside of the other person for you're
getting ahead of yourself because if you
read it if you try and do Tantra by
doing that first you're just gonna end
up having normal sex having really slow
moving at normal sexier don't disturb
the birds so Tantra is to breathe
together and circulate your energy
between yourselves when that when there
is no when sexual arousal is low so that
you can then bring that into your normal
is a taper period yeah so so david deida
way of the superior man has a book and
then he has a series of exercises that
you can do guided with your partner they
are audio programs obviously a partner
has to be a bit open to doing weird
stuff but we've got that weird duck in
there are you we don't know yeah a
master's hand and put it up their arse
so I think weekly reminder nail the bird
weekly reminder nail the bird review the
quality and frequency problem of that
needs to be shared calendar yeah I can't
if it's just your reminder well that's
another top tip for relationships to be
honest check on the show car
calendars coming rate today's podcast
was scheduled on a share calendar except
none of us put it in so then I put it in
like today and all of us were late
I'm just varying degrees you aren't you
late it's more on time than YouTube
that's true that's late mmm so any part
you thought I'm just thinking about
where we'll go from here so the next one
will probably do breakups and cheating
that's gonna be thorny juicy you're
gonna be thorny and then we need to do
single life leave lead gen like purely
gen and pick up will need a white board
we're like what single life yeah we'll
need a white board and I've got a I've
got we'll need to get a lot of my life
done I've got the framework right of why
you need to get off tinder and gun
Instagram yeah so that's it there I'd
love to see if you can make that
framework accessible to people with
under 50,000 followers yeah
so that's easily how and how to use
Instagram instead of tinder even if you
haven't meet on TV that's what should be
cool for the foot he's gonna have to
review some of the lovely questions that
you guys have sent as well yes I've had
so many sent in but the most requested
episode was relationships one or two so
that's exactly what here it is done and
a pint thoughts on relationships as you
move forward I mean none of us are
married and none of us have been married
it just as she was about to
communication like that wasn't the goal
that wasn't like this the secret it's a
common theme throughout everything
though right I think work on making
yourself the best possible companion is
the only thing that's really in your
control like obviously getting into a
relationships and I suppose that can be
can be influenced but like if you
there's some someone I read something
early today he's that guy again that
asked his wife to review it there was
like our relationship to end up in in
bits in tatters because people are like
you know my TV NIMS but but anyway
people are just not ready to be in a
relationship personally emotionally and
they then just put all of us down on you
a lesson and so if you're like on if
you're not wondering why you're in a
series
Federation ships or your relationship
[ __ ] look at yourself look at yourself
first look John Peterson says that like
if you're attract if there's multiple
women and all of them keep rejecting you
guess who the problem hmm
it's not the women it's you it's a big
pride big board of pride to swallow
those yeah that's like it but people
don't want people don't want to concede
the fact that there's something up with
them
mmm like duck up them something love
them I don't know
quietly one duck no and I cracked up all
right any pine thoughts I think next
time let's do why relationships fail
because there's a we've covered about
ten models their failing relationships
but we didn't dive into them fully so
ten reasons why relationships may be
given economy points but I haven't even
nailing the bird on a seven-day cycle
that's why they offer yeah everybody
same you go to the smartphone
[Music]
communication and it is it's just a
theme isn't it throughout all of this
you got two people in a relationship who
were invested with each other and and
and they're too afraid to speak to each
other it's it's insane any surprise yeah
thanks Gabe Anna
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you